これじゃあはじめした場です皆さん浮き輪
ってご存知でしょうか夏のシーズンに
プール行く方いらっしゃると思うんです
けども会にプールに欠かせないものそれ何
か行きはなんですよ泳げない人にとっては
かなり貴重なものでして私も見ての通り
泳げません稲影しかできないんですけども
そんな僕にとって浮き輪がないと始まら
ないぐらい3つの上でふくっていうドって
すごい大事なんですけども
あら損でやばいを見つけていました
いやいやすすごいならそんな願いのうあ
やばいはこちら僕がアマゾンで見た限り
一番
でございました
除染なかなか伝わりづらいと思うんだけど
キュッって膨らませて大きくなるんで
もともとかなり小さいんですけどもこれ
膨らます目でこのサイズなんですよそして
業種と助っ人に2匹4によりますと
もう
ああああああ
ブーバーこれはねー
いいかところから多分マジで見たことない
サイズだしコレナイトプール行ったら絶対
的になる dogs 食らわしてみ
ましょう
弱ってる
[音楽]
2つかな
見れませんでこれ飲み物を置くとかよ嘘言
っちゃうドリンクホルダーだと思うけど
ほら海はグリーンカフェであるのってその
何となればじゃあな a かかな
えっと泊まれるんよこれ
ああああああ
これやばいよいやいやいややだってたん
納期はこれでいいよ
ポーンポンッ
いやーこれすごいなとこれもここでバナナ
ボートの西ぞ
ああああああ
car
ああああああああああああああああああ
ああああああ
ん
というわけで最大と動きが完成しました
[拍手]
超人気アイテムで観戦しましたどうよ
う
やばいよこれは入りきらんも俺やばいよね
パワー
フラミンゴの顔になっておりますしますね
このウィングで羽根の時点でもこれで
バナナボートぐらいの大きさがあるので
amazon 今見たけどで切れてるは
現在お取り扱いしてませんになってるこれ
じゃあ魅力感じ須郷
買いたくなるでしょこれは超巨大からに何
か他にも大きなだったんですけどもこれが
一番いいね帰ってきそうだった10なるの
待ってるんだから浮き輪というよりなんか
いたみたいボートみてねやっぽいなこれが
ベストだった気がします10月16点角を
取った後もこのおったです
yokomo 過ごした方もこれに明大
jal ですよこれしこれで乗ってくれる
んだろうなうわぁ今の4日からでどう考え
ても乗れないことは分かったでこれ
イェーイやはり強いコピーなんとこちらの
動きはお値段
ないんだと思います
このサイズでしょはいまあ普通の木はが
まぁだいたい3000円ぐらいじゃない
ですか
それまあ
10個分って考えて
3万円とがありませんでした大わー高いよ
茶会けどまぁなくてに届く値段というか
54,000円でこの最高級のハミが
できるのであれば俺は全然出せるよって
書くとなんか見ていきましょうかベンチね
これすごくないこれ
もうここでまだ2力でしょまあなんかあれ
だねリムジンの中みたいなんだろう
できれば8人ケソ
リムジンをもうこれすごいの試みな参加者
はムードリングホルダーでございますね
この際じゃあの長旅できるんで23日帰っ
てこれなくなる可能性あるんですよ待って
えっ
もうここはとはこれを入れるために作られ
たものと思ったんですこれでペソとの海の
景色を楽しみながら読めるようっていう気
になったり機能がありまして柱これは何分
何年か2っぽいんですけど
おっ
[音楽]
これはきっと永田ビルのトイレですね
曜日水記念やろこれ本気度何となくこうよ
みんなに見られるけどねそれを隠すような
んじゃないですねこうやって言ってんじゃ
なく何込みままの日がするのびっくりとが
起きるから降りごっこ息の長すぎるホっ
ぽいんだよなこのもありませんかってこと
はやっぱり良い練習がしてくるのを維持し
ております女4どんな女指で今回ですねも
の息を作ったということはもーっちろん旅
に出ますこちらん
ああああああ
湖でございまーすアワーだと思ったしは彼
はだと思ったスネ湖がめちゃだいたい
向こうに時間で400メートルぐらいあり
ましてまぁ実写言うきまーでじゃあ水
ばかり着ることないと思って旅をしつつ
向こうはどれくらいかかるのかなっていう
のをちょっとやってみたいと思います
じゃあ早速乗り込みましょう
神軽い
よしじゃあさっそく水に浙江省者
はいっ
[音楽]
あー
払えこれ軽いぞ
いやーコンドルや葉を振っ
しれません
てやばいやばいじゃあまたそう思って持っ
た
ザッハー戦争を生かしていただきます
[音楽]
こういう奴いねえなんかさ
ちょっと待ってパシャ入って略ちょっと
浮きはかあそうだ言ったよもう欠陥商品が
持ったまま仕事じゃ濡れシステムなんか
ちょっと待ってなんか不安になってきた急
にああそうでさぁ皆さんすいませんこれ
浮き輪なのでばっかなんですよ床に水か
なる部分にはもう正しいという感じですが
ほとんどものとか積んでいきます
いいですねさ大丈夫だまずはけど俺う
気張って紹介してるから船ではなかった
です全てのお部屋がありました生き方です
真ん中には穴が開いてますね ok 全部
雪できました安全のためにライフ
ジャケットを築きましょう皆さん入っ
ツアーの湖危ない度でかなり気を付けて
撮影しております業組合者の協力のもと
作成できておりますので noon また
し引用してないんでこれはで沈没してぜひ
溺れたりして危険があった時の為に一応
救助の方もチューブしておりますのでご
安心ください奥様のアレも準備しましたね
完璧ですこれにすっかり超えていき
ましょうみんなの離婚だけです
ん
あーやは生きなきゃギターで5位
ううっうぅうう ni よこれすごい
いやいやイェイか
これすごいよ
おい
てもさあ息子は歯も磨いてみた
嬉しいじゃないか
あーみんだかぼちゃですねその場合やたか
なんですか御茶ノ水夢だったから皆さんを
忘れだと思うけど俺たちもこれ浮間の中に
売ってある
だけ持っ a 優雅ですね夕方寝たく昨日
に橋の下向かってるねこれ
だって私が開きしちゃいますからね確か
あっちが行きたいよはいですよ
俺はそこに行きたい行きましょうシックっ
ていい
4はいもういいんだけど
ていないハーイ
ん
me それじゃあ a
higher 林じゃあ
はいえーいてるだけ12
12 e 12 led
t 中
[音楽]
ん
で希なに一つだああああ
贈りますうけつ1日だけでああああいい
ですね ok ですこれでまっすぐに彼は
それでは次の出兵5
海は混じった可能性
動い抗議に行くそうですねー
を切る
[音楽]
[拍手]
待ってもう1人も乗客いるんだけどえっ
こいつどうする
何がどう転んでも助からないよしいたけ
困るんだしては連れてるからなそう願って
いますあれこれどっち逆ですこれやばい
やばいやばいやばい
amaran
[音楽]
多い東映
応援
えっ朝日スポット場合じゃないよ
今までのでから左飛燕で一番うまいこっち
もの間のの古谷
[音楽]
いいよいいねぇ進んですっ
すずめ7飽きてが進めちゃうよ
hanachan
aiff 流されています
にはもどってるよ
んだまれ
ai じゃあ何スポーツになったら母これ
だけですああああ
そっちかい are you doing
r
en goo
俺はこっちに行けば
泉とってもまあ風の流れでさあ
動くんだから気付いたらここにいたよん
気づいたらねああああ
yeah
tl ありがたう大丈夫
あっていません
マギー
行くぞ voodoo
入っちゃっていいいい
[音楽]
与えて30分ぐらいやれば湖の端から端目
100m いけることがわかりません
あっ打ってみては作ら期待おります
nice 鯉がとかそう感じたすごあった
し後からきてたんでよく技で切ったなお前
どうせこりゃとか持ってる
前々期は0
0ああああああ
[音楽]
ブーブー
エロ